[Music]
we had a listen to your heart breaking
goodbye I can't get there the fantasies
to come are you won and winners
everybody push it breathe this is your
listen to your heart season 1 episode 6
big ol finale and Nashville recap grab
your glasses it's time for roses and
roses a howdy y'all it's me Lauren Zima
and we're in Nashville for the big
finale of listen to your heart I'm
wearing my version of cowboy things this
is a collared shirt with stars on it
stars because we're making stars right I
don't know but we have a winner of
listen to your heart what did you think
of the finale let me know in the
comments below let's get to it
and because it's the finale we've got to
celebrate we've got some roses and roses
champagne listen to your oh oh so you
guys what did you think of the finale
episode I have mixed feelings on it
varied thoughts a smorgasbord of
opinions let's get to it
that's not enough when it comes to the
champagne you don't want to be in the
shallow you know what's safe
we weren't in the shallow because we
lost Rudi we're gonna get to it we're
gonna get to it okay just throw things
maybe much later what else are you doing
okay make a mess clean it up the
quarantine life so this is the finale so
to start things off we get an emotional
sad happy romantic
conflicting montage don't drink for
every look back it's just been a real
relief to find you we have Chris and Bri
and they're so in love I really got
goose bumps during this one especially
seeing that moment when they first met
also much has changed and we have Matt
and Rudy that was intense I don't know
about their love but I know I love
watching them and we have Jaime and
Trevor Anna and I wrote down solid I am
falling in love with you I'm falling in
love with you too
and now we're in Nashville now Chris is
saying they're going to perform two
songs together and they're going to have
fantasy suites because at the end of the
date there will be a fantasy suite card
and Jamie's like oh ho and everyone else
is like don't drink for all the silent
phases even Chris is like if you guys
knew about The Bachelor you'd know what
fantasy suites are if you're a part of
bachelor nation like Jamie is you know
what that means but we are staying in a
hotel a hotel in Nashville and if I'm
being honest I didn't love the decor it
felt quite elder it felt quite dated and
not in a charming way although that has
its own charms 19 Melanie a righteous
brother oh now they're getting their
final song choices and my problem
everybody was I want to watch Matt and
Rudy sing everything I do I enjoy
watching them perform the best even
though I know their love connection
isn't the strongest who did you think
got the best final songs let me know in
the comments below
now I'm mad and Rudy we left off with
their band date of a performance last
week they're on stage velcro holding it
all together their Elmer's glue stick
that's about to dry out they always dry
it out didn't they we try to use those
for a childhood project and if you left
that cap off even a little bit too much
oh you had to buy a new one
not the worst business model okay and
you know I'm not shocked once again
drink for every time Matt doesn't know I
just don't know if I'm not that same
point I love words at that same place
Matt if you don't know just go okay
we're getting to it we're getting to it
now because of Matt's indecisiveness
Rudi is having a panic attack making me
have a very key tax and she needs us
snuggle and I wrote down I know that
feeling over then back to Jamie and
Trevor because remember Chris Harrison
said that these couples need to figure
out if they are really really really
really really really really really
really really really really committed to
each other so Jamie makes an interesting
point that she lives in Nashville and
apparently Trevor plans to move to
Nashville and I already live here and
he's planning on moving here even though
there's something about Jamie and Trevor
that I don't know bores me a little bit
it did make me think well they've
already solved a big problem that many
bachelor couples often face which is the
problem of long distance so are they
good to go do you know tell me so in the
comments below and back to Chris and Bri
they are rehearsing and it's so cute
he's so supportive have no problems
oh my gosh she's something so good I'm
good too The Bachelor producers they
need a problem and don't drink every
time I go back and forth now it's back
to Matt and Rudy and you know they're
living quarantine vibes aren't they
stuck in the present not sure of
tomorrow having difficulty moving
forward because they don't know how they
plan on that note okay sue don't drink
for all of their quarantine vibes Rudy
is doing deep meditative breaths matt is
on his daily walk and Rudy says she's
dying slowly hoga dying in here slowly
it's fine he does crack me up love her
by the way in case you missed it I did
speak to Rudy about her relationship
with Matt and the interview brought her
to tears so check that out at easy
online commerce aimless blub
so what will Matt do and then and then
and then and then I was brought back to
the office again we mentioned it last
week well this week I was taken to the
fire drill episode where they're all
having to escape and they're like it's
happening it's happening it's happening
oh my god okay it's happening everybody
stay calm it's happening it's happening
it's happening they were trapped
everyone for himself
Matt's gonna be honest so Matt tells
Rudy he doesn't think they are at the
same level as the other couples it's
just hard for me to say we can go up
there and be at the same level as their
ass yeah don't drink for the whole time
Rudy's gut-wrenchingly sobbing that was
rough you guys what did you think of
Matt's delivery of that message and did
you think they should stay or go
and I couldn't believe the answer I was
truly shocked they're gonna go there are
Jackson an ally we were far from the
shallowness I knew that we were still in
it with Matt but I what I just wanted to
see them saying I'm being selfish hey I
just wanted to take another look at you
that was me doing a an old school window
Jackson had a he I don't know like an
Escalade though so hey I just wanted to
take another look at it's a power window
I just want to take another look at you
I mean don't drink for every time Matt
said he's just not there I just wasn't
there
we just
weren't there we just we just weren't
exactly there so they're going they're
just getting in one of Jackson mains
Escalades where are their bags did they
just not want to stay in a haunted hotel
again what do you think
[Music]
oh and as they get into the car we're
hearing the sound of them singing
together it's too many ghosts oh good
then we know they're done because Matt
said I'm gonna miss you what would you
guys do I miss you guys what did you
think of this moment I was truly ripped
got edged split in two as Rudy was
leaving that was watching her car he
appeared to be hesitating on the one
hand I thought not chase that car down
on the other hand I thought no actually
don't because we were finally honest
about your lack of real feelings for
Rudy he's not gonna chase down the car
but he does say Rudy is so talented yeah
because it's a talent crush he's so
talented it's ridiculous did Jackson
alley just have to hang like crushes I
think you're beautiful really how did
you guys feel mad to handle this
situation I wasn't mad at him I
appreciated that he was honest with Rudy
and he was crying and he said he hated
depriving people of her talent which was
so beautiful and I thought yeah I'm mad
you did do that bothers me that I took a
little bit of that away from her to go
get to performing it and let people hear
her sing
[Music]
okay but they're gone and like Ally we
have to move on so it's time for the
fantasy suites Wow so we I'm Trevor and
Jamie and they are talking being
vulnerable I want to take that risk
because you're worth it
exposing themselves just like he's
exposing his knees were those pants and
Trevor makes a good point says Jamie has
been his girl since day one since day
one it's been you I know that we
questioned
Trevor's integrity in the beginning of
this season but he's only ever been into
Jamie he's stuck with her baby so do you
trust him maybe let me know in the
comments below
and that's the deal with Chris and Bri -
so at this point which couple did you
think was stronger christen Bri have
said I love you Jamie and Trevor have
not what's the smarter move comments
below and did the right couples make the
final two we don't have no
[Music]
but Trevor and Jamie decide to go to the
fatter Zuzu weeds and you know what
let's have some fun
we're here in this kid han ido Dulles
enjoy ourselves you would agree let's
drink for the great they say Jamie says
Trevor seized her he sees me and Trevor
says he's already won with Jamie I feel
like I've already won and they say
they're gonna eat all the chocolate
covered strawberries this strawberries
oh yeah so we're definitely offers and
now Chris and brave this is a secondary
microphone I've been using in case I
mess up the audio in the last night so
Chris and regal on their final date and
oh surprise so they're on their final
date where they will decide if they're
going to go into the fantasy is so wheat
and Brie is like we gotta slow down I'm
not in a rush to get anywhere you know
we're moving too fast I first want to
get to know you on an emotional level I
don't want to be into Matt and I want to
make sure it happens at the right time
what kind of like I said into Matt I
miss Matt Andrew yeah but I meant the
word intimate intimate
so yeah were you guys surprised by this
restart saying she doesn't want to move
too fast in her relationship with Chris
but remember she's the one who dropped
the l-bomb on stage in front of an
audience once they get their fantasy
suite card in he's not how Brie's name
is spelled this whole time I've been
spelling it like the cheese that'll tell
you where my head's at in the chlorin
cheese confusion she tells Chris she
needs to get to know him on an emotional
level I first want to get to know you on
an emotional level aren't they in love
were you as baffled by this let me know
in the comments below how I forgot about
my champagne keep celebrating once again
I am just like beyond happy that you
really just are on the same page he says
it's good it's chill well let's not go
to the fantasy suite babe don't get your
ax let's go back to Jaime and Trevor and
everybody buckle up sit back grab your
glass because then woken up together in
chic White Rose I definitely commute
east and waking up to this handsome man
don't give them those robes oh where do
you go at night and hashtag Lauren chic
drink for them ordering every [ __ ]
thing off the menu this is all I needed
made a plate of Joel nice drink for
every donut champagne wishes and glazed
donut during games what's your favorite
donut let me know in the comments below
I like a blueberry cake
but while JP and Trevor are literally
sharing food lady in the [ __ ] style but
with a doughnut which I actually
appreciate brie is regretting and not
sharing the fantasy suite with Chris any
form of intimacy does bond to people and
bring them closer and I maybe we're a
little off today because of that and
what did you think of her comments here
because I was frustrated I'm like girl
that was your choice and I thought it
was really about her voice yes I said it
I think that brief was more frustrated
that they hadn't been intimate because
she felt it was effective in performance
and pomp that should not be your reason
let me know in the comments below now
Chris Henry are fully falling apart
while Jaime and Trevor are coming closer
together so who will win it all if the
performances well that doesn't make a
sound I just see my breath in their
corona okay so they are on their way and
don't drink for breathe dead stare face
in the car she's like how many people do
you think will be there how many people
be there do you think well yeah well
it's crazy so soon
should we have been intimate well I'm
really creeping myself out okay I'm
sorry it was that too much too scary for
you I don't know you've seen some stuff
and don't drink for every time Jamie and
Trevor kiss in the carpet for each other
after that penalty sue and ask for the
hookups and I guess we got it and don't
drink for Chris wearing not just a
printed scarf this time but also a
printed shirt prints on prints on prints
so we have our audience members who seem
to all have been told to wear shades of
pink
don't drink for every pink oh you know
what let's go crazy before the end here
guys don't drink for every star on my
shirt
don't do that a little filler up for the
finale performance I think so huh yeah
it's about to boil over who will so
we're getting ready and Trevor and Jamie
looked great I have to say very star
quality moments I didn't realize what
great hair Trevor had till now
I thank God he's not wearing that in the
nakid anymore so Jamie never looked
great and then Bree is sparkling and
then a bold lip and Chris looks like a
detective ready to take down a
perpetrator what was that look skinny
tie and a watch and a cup of coffee
I said interrogate me sir question is
can he solved the mystery of Bree in
time to win this whole thing
don't drink for all of Jamie's vocal
warm-ups she is not messing around and
while we're on the topic of outfits
Chris Harrison in a full tux moment okay
and we're getting our judges and Kailyn
and Jason are here
ante Diggs is here I know you got jewel
is here give it up for jewel
loved her debut album very influential
for me as I was you know in those years
of being a young insecure girl worried
that a boy would never like me and that
I wouldn't have any friends
sorry just reflecting okay oh and a pre
Corona Rita Wilson is here and we are
very glad that Rita is well we had to
see her now so it's everything is
through the lens of the pandemic so this
one we have four judges so don't drink
for every judge mmm Jamie and Trevor
Jamie and Trevor go first and they're
singing Unchained Melody
[Music]
I couldn't tell I think they did kind of
a cool spin on it and I have to say I
was thinking imagine that really singing
it I said it I'm so I know they
shouldn't have been together but I
wanted them to be together for him to
sing oh but then Trevor hit a high note
oh he slapped me right in the face with
that didn't know Trevor could do that
okay
so I was really I liked it they put a
spin on it it suited their voices what
did you think I know from when I asked
that what does a conductor do question
that some of you have some real musical
pedigree in the audience and I
appreciate it so I'd love for you to
tell me truly what did you think let me
know really let me know in comments
below two songs so then they're gonna do
speechless it's baffi and the judge made
a good point they said that while they
were looking at each other they could
have also been performing out into the
audience your nerves kind of told on you
and that you were leaning a little bit
too much on each other I wanted to see
more of you kind of independent and I
thought that was a good lesson you guys
to remember you could be in a
partnership but you still have to be
independently strong so a very good
metaphor or analogy which one is it do
we also have some English educators in
the house have you received me like this
levorg no no it's Chris and Bri these
are supposed to make curtains so you
guys they had been shaky they had not
been feeling intimate and then
[Music]
was it just me or were they like singing
intimacy adage father
[Music]
I know this sounds really weird you guys
but I really felt the connection
[Music]
like I was watching Brees eyes and I was
hearing Chris's voice and I was feeling
like they were making love vocally to
make you feel
[Music]
do you agree let me know in the comments
below give me the I mean their eyes the
notes was we crying definitely my
favorite performance ever from Chris and
breathe at this point I'm feeling like
lick glitched it and the winners are
Christian bling Chris and breathe
[Applause]
[Music]
oh and Jamie and Trevor still kiss and
that's nice and then Chris and Bree are
on the tour bus and they're giving each
other the final roses and of course
they're singing that's what we do oh and
at the end here I think they're
recording the song
[Music]
I love this love at the end card thing
so how did you guys feel should Chris
and Bri have been the big winners at the
end of all this they were the only
couple to say they were in love with
each other and they didn't really have
any problems throughout the whole thing
so it tracked now our Jamie and Shriver
still together
I'm gonna guess no I'm Matt and Rudy I
don't think so
our Natasha and Ryan I'm gonna say a
negative but I might have to insert a
vlog here to update you all depending on
what is said on social media after the
finale and ultimately what did you think
of listen to your heart you know it's
the first season of a new show and I do
think that there are some kinks to be
worked out if the show continues but
ultimately Chris and Bri are a real love
story and so we raise a glass to it
because in these times in the quarantine
times we need all the silver linings we
can get thank you for watching roses and
Rose day as we have recapped season 1 of
The Bachelor presents listen to your
heart I love you guys so much truly and
deeply especially during these
quarantine Correns it has been wonderful
to still get to connect with you on
these shows so what should we do next
should we do roses and rose' for the
bachelors greatest seasons of all time
thing should we do Juan Pablos season of
The Bachelor ahead of klaris season with
the Bachelorette so that we can look
back at where Claire came from let me
know in the comments below you can find
me on Twitter Instagram tick-tock and
the app cameo will be back and everybody
remember to listen to your heart and
I'll see your brains love you guys bye
[Music]